you know what i haven't done for a while
[ __ ] about youtube
[Music]
hey folks so uh yeah uh i am gonna be
kind of complaining about youtube but uh
this one's gonna be a little bit of a
trip a little bit of a journey because
we gotta kind of talk about some of the
weird quirks of youtube and the ways in
which youtube attempts to emulate other
platforms
usually by doing what other platforms do
either precisely or
almost precisely but worse
so let's first acknowledge yes this is
my living i'm biting the hand that feeds
me
that hand is currently um also smacking
me mildly across the face so i'm gonna
i'm gonna bite at it just a little bit
how is it smacking me i'll get there
i will get there stick with me
ultimately where i'm going is i'm going
to be talking about the shorts format
but like i said we've got a little bit
of a journey to get there now when it
comes to streaming video content
youtube
is monolithic
it's practically a monopoly when it
comes to
free to upload user made content
obviously there are other streaming
services out there but you know they
have their own unique ips disney plus
netflix hbo max paramount plus et cetera
et cetera et cetera when it comes to
the users create the content youtube
is the biggest game in town no question
but
that's for long form
there are other things out there that
have kind of taken over and dominated
short form in various ways initially
there were things like snapchat and then
instagram instituted its stories
function and then youtube instituted its
stories function where
short videos get uploaded for a certain
amount of time and then go away
they just copy-pasted that off of other
people who were doing it the shorts
function is more recent and appears to
largely be aped from tick-tock
but uh i just want to talk in general
about
some of the ways in which youtube's
algorithm
does and doesn't work the first thing we
need to acknowledge before saying
anything about the algorithm is it is
changing
it is always changing and it actually
kind of has to as annoying as it is for
creators to not know what is going to be
favored in the algorithm next week and
barely know what's what's favored in it
now that's actually kind of necessary
pretty much any time somebody figures
out the algorithm they then begin to
game the system and that's what can
result in things like that period a few
years ago where these
bizarre children's videos of like these
really poorly rendered cgi things of
like a pregnant else and spider-man were
just dancing around with the joker
it was some weird stuff and that
happened because it was gaming the way
the algorithm was set up at the time dan
olsen at folding ideas did a pretty good
video breakdown of that specifically if
you don't remember that happening but
that's one way in which the algorithm
can
fail
because once anybody figures out how is
it currently working what's it favoring
well
like i said they're going to game the
system that can also result in
unintended consequences sometimes
youtube has a very big gaming scene and
actually it used to be bigger than it
currently is
part of the reason for that was
let's plays and long plays in particular
of things like minecraft started coming
in at the same time that the algorithm
was reconfigured to give more favoritism
to longer form
videos that people watched as much as
possible out of chunk and
long play video game footage yeah
that really lends itself to that youtube
had wanted gaming to become one of the
biggest things on the platform but it
became that anyway just because of the
timing and the timing can also benefit
some really shady things because
the types of videos made by say flat
earthers happen to coincide with the
types of content in terms of general
structure that youtube won at the time
uh this is one of many reasons why flat
earth is not quite as popular as it used
to be the algorithm was changed and
doesn't favor these things anymore but
why am i even bringing up the algorithm
well the algorithm ultimately what it is
trying to do although it shifts in terms
of what it prioritizes you know views
versus lengths versus a number of
interactions etc etc etc
ultimately what the algorithm is
intending to do is to put content in
front of the people who will want to
watch it and will therefore watch any
given video the longest that is the
point of the algorithm
and
sometimes
the algorithm smiles on you
it's actually arguable whether it's ever
really smiled on me i've done okay i
mean i've done well enough for this to
be my living but that's taken 10 years
and also uh like i've never properly
gone viral like nearly every uh other
youtuber i know of anywhere near my size
or anyone who i know is doing this
professionally has had at least one
video
go properly viral like million views are
up i've never even come close to that
but i'm not really here to [ __ ] about
the algorithm the reason i bring up the
algorithm is because we need to talk
about shorts
as i said we were going to get there now
the shorts format basically just
is
tick-tock at least it wants to be its
default is vertical it's a minute or
shorter basically it's trying to stop
the siphoning off of short form video
comment to tick-tock and the intention
of the shorts format was to try and claw
some of that back basically youtube with
the implementation of things like
stories shorts they want people to stay
on youtube for as much as possible they
want basically what facebook had a
little while back which was that there
was a time and in some parts of the
world this is actually still the case
but at least for a time there was an
america you got so much stuff off of
facebook
you know you had your friends fees but
you also got your local news you would
check the national news you check fandom
spaces you check the facebook pages for
businesses you might you may or may not
do your actual shopping off of facebook
but you would get ads and get directed
to places to then go do shopping it all
filtered through facebook youtube as
popular as it is for user uploaded
content
for other things related to it other
bits of video content shorter things
people were getting them elsewhere
instagram stories tick tock
youtube would rather you stay here and
get that same kind of content on youtube
as well so that you stay
here now
since shorts is kind of attempting to be
their answer to tick tock and ironically
tick tock now seems to be trying to
muscle in on youtube certainly by
allowing for the upload of videos up to
10 minutes long although it still
defaults to vertical and trying to edit
something for vertical and up like
it's not ideal tic talks a long way off
for being like the go-to place to do
something long form but they're now both
trying to muscle in on their territory
but
to focus on tick tock for a minute
while i would say i've never really
properly gone viral on youtube i have
several times gone properly viral on
tick tock uh not on my current account
my account that was actually obliterated
here's the thing about going viral
it kind of sucks
like legitimately if you're on tick tock
you already know this phrase if you're
not i'll explain what this is but
sometimes you'll hear people talking
about
i'm on the wrong side of tick tock or my
video went up on the wrong side of tick
tock now what is meant by that is the
different sides of tick tock which a lot
of which have cute little names you know
bi talk
witch talk craft talk etc etc etc all
sorts of stuff
when the algorithm is working well and
honestly tick tocks algorithm is pretty
good at funneling to you the kinds of
stuff that you have shown an interest in
and are enjoying
it's so good that the times that it
fails really jump out to you
but
here's the thing
when people say i'm on the wrong side of
tick tock or my video showed up on the
wrong side of tick tock what that means
is something is showing up not for its
intended audience
but for people who
maybe don't want to see it
people who are responding harshly to it
so when i say i've gone viral as i said
that happened a number of times and
most of the time
i would say
if i can think back
i'd say i went properly viral on tick
tock on my original account
six times
and five out of those six were a
nightmare
because what happens when you go viral
is the video does so well for whatever
reason but it does so well that the
algorithm goes oh this is doing so well
that we're going to take it beyond
just the um
the people that this is originally
intended for in the algorithm we're
going to show it to more people we're
going to spread it further because it's
connecting with people clearly
but here's one of the things about tick
tock and this is also true of youtube
any interaction
is engagement
and it does not matter if that
engagement is positive
or negative
so
what would happen when my stuff would go
viral on tick-tock and
as i said sometimes it would be because
it was already doing really well and
then it would just be posted to a wider
array of stuff on tick tock sometimes it
would just be grabbed by somebody
somewhere possibly accidentally
and it would just show up in their feed
but then
somebody who wasn't meant for
who would look at me
and insult me
or threaten me
would not only
do that in my comments
they would then
share it with other people and saying
stuff like
i had to see this therefore you do too
and basically it becomes a loop that
spreads me out further and further into
the side of tick tock i don't want to be
in because again any interaction is
engagement so the fact that these people
while they are being incredibly nasty
and i would have to block them
on mass i would there were days where i
would spend literally hours of my day
blocking people
off my account because of this of the
harassment and the cruelty in just the
sense that they had no interest
in me or they
thought i was gross
which you know what you can think
whatever the hell you want i don't care
but i shouldn't have to deal with you
clogging up my comment feed
just hit not interested and move on
but they interact with it and then the
algorithm pushes it to more people like
them as they continue to tag other
people like them and it becomes a
spiraling nightmare so why am i talking
about tick tock in relation to youtube
shorts
well
as i said youtube shorts is youtube's
attempt to aid tick tocks um
approach and type of content again not
completely but
relatively close
and it's very clearly working off a
different
algorithm than the main videos are
which also makes sense
the
people that you would push the shorts to
maybe that's a wider range you may have
noticed on youtube that you have a feed
for shorts that is completely separate
from like from something like your
subscription feeds or your
recommendations
it's being handled separately and
they've clearly modeled the algorithm
off of how tick tock does the algorithm
here's the reason all of this is on my
mind
for the past few months
i had been noticing a lot of
very nasty comments and look i get nasty
comments on a daily basis that's been
happening
for a very long time but i noticed an
uptick
and specifically
it was on my shorts
the things that we're getting the most
dislikes which
only i'm aware of because they took
visibility off the dislike button and
again a dislike still counts as
engagement
so as far as the algorithm is concerned
you are actually boosting the a video
whenever you hit the dislike button
and doesn't matter how nasty your
comment is a comment is a comment
negative engagement spends just as well
as positive engagement as far as youtube
is concerned this is something that
people are enact are interacting with
are engaged with that means we can
charge the advertisers more to run ads
on it because look how engaged people
are oh but they hate it who cares
we got their eyeballs
that's worth money
so as i said i was seeing a lot
on
my shorts
now
most of the more on the shorts that i
would have kind of expected to see some
nasty pushback on i.e ones that i did
talking about
say
jk rowling or anything related to that
disagreeing with
pretty much anything she says about
gender because you know it's all wrong
but we're not going to get into that
here right now
but
my point being nasty comments on that i
kind of expect it was throwing me off
that that they were still coming like
weeks or months after the short went up
that struck me as a little odd and my
initial thought i wondered like has this
video been passed around in turf spaces
somewhere like on some uh turf forum
that but
it wasn't a mass pylon it was a drip
feed i'd get a couple a day and then
maybe go quiet for a few days then i get
another five
it was weird
then it all clicked in my head
when i put a short up
with my thoughts on the recent
she-hulk trailer i was
flooded with comments from people
who thought it was clever to claim that
i looked like she-hulk
i think they were trying to say i looked
manish
have you seen she-hulk in the comics
that's not an insult and it's actually
very funny to me that they thought it
was but they clearly meant it as such
but more revealing to me or how many
people who gave me variations of
what am i looking at what the hell is
this
why is this on my feed these were
clearly from people
who didn't know my channel and i'd never
seen anything from me as is also
evidenced by the fact that i was seeing
these comments at all because i make
very
liberal use of the hide commenter
function which once i activate that it
doesn't actually stop you from leaving a
comment but no one will ever see it i
won't see it and it's not visible to
anybody
and i use that feature a lot it's
basically like blocking accept it
doesn't actually prevent people from
being able to see your channel they can
still see your channel they just can't
meaningfully interact with it anymore
i use that a lot so these weren't people
who like knew my stuff and suddenly this
is what made them snap and get nasty at
me
the algorithm
being used for shorts
pushed me
in front of the eyes
of people
who are not okay
seeing
a trans or gender non-conforming person
and it's been kind of frustrating
because as far as numbers go
there are times that my shorts are more
successful than my videos
so youtube is theoretically
rewarding me
with more views and more interactions
but they're rewarding me by punishing me
and pushing
my face in front of people who are going
to hurl insults at it
my standard
like to dislike ratios on most videos is
over ninety percent i'm not going to say
never gets lower than that there are a
few times where i've gotten on the wrong
side of some fandoms whoever like wait
i'm sorry who did i annoy where it's got
down into 70s but like that's not very
common
the dislike ratio on these shorts
yeah that is not typical and it happens
relatively reliably on the shorts
again that's not actually a reason for
me to stop using the shorts format as i
said any engagement is
engagement and
even a
mountain of dislikes
pushes it further
and further
showing it to more and more people
who want to insult me
youtube
when you set out to
try and replicate tick-tock
i don't know if you probably realized
all the problems that you were gonna
port over
or maybe you knew when you didn't care
but it was a revelation that hit me
when i really stopped and thought about
why the she-hulk video in particular
and now that i've sorted it out
i kind of needed to cleanse myself of it
youtube
trying to be everything it can every
video format it can possibly be and the
shorts format which i like well enough
and i make use of boy does it kind of
make my day a little bit more irritating
though
because of how the algorithm
pushes it forward
and how those
feeds the shorts feed
is more likely to push people in front
of you that you haven't seen before then
apparently your main recommendations are
because you know how rare it is for new
people to see that stuff from me
yeah
so that's uh my
i don't know how long has it been two
years i don't know
my semi-annual biannual something
complaining about youtube
i think it's been a while i was overdue
for this
what are your thoughts on any of this
nonsense
have you encountered any similar things
if you yourself are a youtube creator
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it i mentioned this is my
living patreon is what really enables
that i do make money off of youtube but
uh i couldn't live off that alone and so
without the patreon help i couldn't be
doing this right now not as my living
not as my full-time job
but even if you can't support me that
way there's also memberships here
there's links to merchandise i have
books for sale et cetera et cetera even
if you aren't able to do that like share
and subscribe help me out like i said
all engagement
does help even hit the dislike if you
feel like it what the heck
nah don't ah people will just uh just
because they said oh you said i could ah
whatever do whatever you want because
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right i've got thanks to give for my
patreon supporters robin moore zubin
fulla turak the thing that goes doink in
the anime oliver b linda walters
imudelki the oath of boyd tt for nobulax
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shayla gourley and brendan larose
the rats and i thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]